welcome to the uh subcommittee work
session for Senate Bill 54 of the
science technology and energy committee
will start this morning as usual by
rising and joining representative Thomas
as he leads us in the pledge
okay once again we are here for a
subcommittee work session on Senate bill
54. our goal for the day is to get some
questions answered
and then discuss whether or not we can
make a recommendation to the full
committee on the disposition of Center
bill 54.
this is not a public hearing we're not
going to ask ask people to come up to
the table and testify on the bill what
we are going to do is we're going to ask
a series of questions and ask people in
the who are assembled here with us today
and we thank you for being here
if you feel you would like to answer the
question please raise your hand and then
we'll invite you to the front table
to answer the question
now it's possible that more than one
person would want to
offer an answer to the question
we will call on more than one person if
we feel that the question hasn't
adequately been answered or if there's a
possible more than one answer let's put
it that way
so that's the way we'll we will proceed
this morning as you can see we have five
members of the subcommittee plus one
other member of the sdne committee
the members of the subcommittee are to
my right
representative James Summers
myself reference to my left
representative JD Bernardi
representative Kat McGee and
representative Tom Corman and
representative Doug Thomas is here as a
interested member of the committee
as you know all members of the committee
are invited to attend
subcommittee work sessions
and we may during the course of the day
have other committee members pop in and
out
so
with that as an introduction are there
any questions from committee members
about how we plan to proceed today
seeing none let's get right to it
so I have two lists of questions here
one developed by
each of our caucuses the majority in the
minor minority caucus and so what we'll
do here is we'll ask I'll ask a question
from
this list in my right hand first and
then we'll ask a question from this list
in my left hand second
and we'll get our answers
from the interested parties that way
so the first question on the list is
should the department of energy issue
rfps instead of utilities is there
anybody here who would offer an answer
to that question
please come forward
Dan from the Department of energy
please state your name and uh who you
represent yep Dan Phelan uh represent
the department of energy it has been our
position that the department should not
issue the rfps for a few reasons the
primary of which is resources and after
that is expertise the utilities have
uh issued rfps in other states and have
a familiarity with the process the
department is not familiar with the
day-to-day detail of the RFP and would
not be able to under current Staffing
provide the adequate support that an RFP
would need
okay thank you uh does anyone need
clarification or elaboration on that
answer
does anyone else out there like to
respond
Ms Connors
good morning Molly Connors for the
record New England power generators
Association I can speak to the practices
in other states in the state of Rhode
Island and in the state of Connecticut
I'm sorry I misspoke in the state of
Connecticut in the state of
Massachusetts it is the Department of
energy resources which is the equivalent
of the New Hampshire Department of
energy that issues the RFP they assure
that they have the resources the the
department has the resources to go
through this by ensuring that the
applicants
sign agreements that allow third parties
like ISO New England to review the
applications and the information in the
RFP the state policies have done this
because they find that the conflict of
interest that the incumbent utilities
have is so strong that they need to make
sure that there is a system in place
that doesn't inadvertently tip the
scales even further for the incumbent
utilities this is because the incumbent
utilities often have an affiliate a
company that is proposing
proposing a solution to the RFP similar
to their competition so our ever source
for example may be in a position where
it is it has a project that's competing
for the RFP along with other companies
and we've seen that in Massachusetts in
addition to having the the government
agency in support with ISO New England
and the utilities review the responses
to the rfps they have an independent
evaluator that's brought in that
monitors the behavior of the utilities
when they do it
and have it answer any questions thank
you
okay
yes go ahead
don't forget to turn on your mic
forget about the audience which is
strange since I sang for so long you
would think I would know get the mic on
um this point about having a third party
um be responsible or an independent
um expert that would be able to help
with the RFP process is one that had
been brought up last week and
um I actually had a zoom yesterday with
Mike Licata of eversource around
um how that could be inserted into the
RFP section
um and so I we have some proposed
language which is electric distribution
utilities shall engage an independent
third party to perform a cost-benefit
analysis of any agreements received in
response to our request for proposals
such analysis should be provided to the
commission as part of a utilities
petition for approval of any purchase
power agreements resulting from the RFP
process so this independent third party
would be to evaluate the rfps to bring
that expertise but there's also a piece
in terms of developing the rfps that we
think there probably should be language
around as well
um so I just wanted to mention that
that's something we had discussed and
eversource was certainly you know happy
to do that they
um we're fine with that Edition
specific thank you for uh investigating
that where in the
language of the bill with this new
language so section two is the purchase
power agreements request for proposals
right yeah and we just created a section
five
so it will go after section four right
yeah
okay
is there any further comment
Mr Phelan
you can stay where you are Molly since
you also have a comment
that said him uh respond first because I
saw his hand first and then you next
great so the department did have some
concerns with that provision uh so to
say that the department is not putting
out the RFP doesn't mean that the
department is not going to have a role
in oversight
we intend to fully represent the
interests of New Hampshire repairs
before the Public Utilities Commission
if and when a contract is brought
forward
uh there is a bit of concern about
changing who the onus is on so the
utility should in bringing forward this
contract make a good case for why it is
a good deal for New Hampshire rate
payers hopefully they will do so by
presenting a benefit cost analysis and
if they do not the department is ready
with the funding in section four current
section 4 to attempt that
um
so there's concern that this would be
redundant because the department would
then go out and hire its own Consultants
to perform some of this similar work and
the cost of this potential new third
party would be recovered from ratepayers
increasing overall costs of the of the
contract so those are our concerns oh
okay there's one more hand in the back
from Tom Franz who would like to make a
quick comment could you come forward Tom
thank you
and then Molly I'm going to let you
speak after that I just want to add
something that uh
the department also wants to point out
that we we end the Office of Consumer
Advocate have input into the RFP ahead
of time before it's issued so it's not
like there's no oversight in utilities
it's going to issue this RFP without any
any input from us or from the office
consumer Advocate and I would think that
a utility that
she always say it doesn't pay any
attention to our comments in the RFP
would probably find it even a rockier
road when they come in with the proposal
later
thank you
thank you yes go ahead turn on your mic
please yes
um so in section three I'm sorry it's
section two which is purchase power
agreements but then it's um
numeral three
um there's also an adjustment there
with language after the word consumer
advocate so I'll just read you the
suggestion and this is so there's
Communications both ways so it starts
electric distribution utilities shall
consult with the Department of energy in
the office of the consumer Advocate on
all issues related to such requests for
proposal prior to issuance including the
criteria and scoring to be used in the
review process to the request for
proposals and then the next sentence is
the department and the office of the
consumer Advocate and then inserted is
shall engage an independent third party
with utility purchase power agreement
expertise to help provide any such
consultation within 60 days from the
date each draft requested for proposal
is provided for its review so the part
that's inserted is just shell engage a
third part an independent third party
with utility purchase power agreement
expertise to help
so the idea is that on the front end it
will be the department and the consumer
Advocate who would be working with a
consultant to determine how the RFP will
be crafted that goes out and then on the
back end it would be in the utilities
hands to hire an independent third party
to evaluate the rfps and make a
recommendation in terms of the cost
benefit analysis to the consumer and all
of that was added with the idea that
reliability and cost were the two things
we were trying to solve for or the
primary things that
we heard were at issue and without
without those two pieces I think then
it's a lot murkier how how we get there
and um
so
that's it
okay thank you
does anyone have any comment on the
suggestion that we add language to
suggest that the department and the
consumer Advocate shall engage an
independent third party
uh as described in the language Molly
you go first and then Mike Licata might
have a comment yeah I would like to
speak to something that um Mr frond said
which is that this would automatically
increase costs for ratepayers I disagree
with that I think it's possible for the
developers who are proposing these
projects to put a portion or a fee on
top for the application this is not an
uncommon practice we do it when we try
to register our cars and ISO New England
for example does you know charge
applicants for the mere benefit of
entering the the queue so I think that
this would be considered the cost of
business and something that doesn't need
to necessarily go on the rate payers who
again have no say in the matter I would
also just like to offer some
observations we've made from
Massachusetts which is about to issue
its fourth RFP for offshore wind or
large-scale Canadian Hydro for the first
three times they they did have the
utilities sort of do all of this work
and the independent evaluator found in
multiple cases is that the utility in
this in this case ever Source but I
don't think it's fair to single out one
incumbent utility in that case the
independent evaluator found troubling
Behavior by the incumbent utility as
they attempted to make the to tip the
scales in favor of their own projects so
in the case I'm thinking of one was
Northern Pass and one was an offshore
wind project so I think it's almost
unfair to put the utilities in this
position because there is so much money
at stake both were ratepayers and for
the utilities it's almost setting them
up to fail and I do appreciate that um
that states don't necessarily have the
expertise or the resources in-house
which is why in Massachusetts it's the
department of the Attorney General and
the department of energy resources that
issues the RFP and the requests for the
independent evaluator and with that I'll
go sit down thank you
thank you those are good comments
appreciate that Molly
so Mr locata did you have a comment to
make about the proposal to
require a third party independent third
party
investigator or evaluator to look at
these rfps
I I do just a little bit of background
um and not speaking to the provisions
that representative McGee said related
to the Department of energy and the
consumer Advocate they can represent
their own agencies uh the language uh
around the utilities engaging uh a
third-party independent an independent
third party to conduct the cost benefit
analysis uh
eversource thought that this might be
helpful uh language it was consistent
with some of the language that
representative McGee was suggesting
around the other agencies and really the
goal of that is to have a third party
who is assisting in that evaluation that
these are extremely complicated analysis
that have to go on you're essentially
um you know doing a predictive analysis
of uh you know the energy markets going
out multiple years
um you know there's there's a lot of
computation that goes into that and
having a third party to to review to
conduct that analysis we thought was
both helpful
um in terms of expediency but also
helpful in terms of really
providing
Assurance to the commission that it's
not just eversource saying hey this
one's the lowest cost that's higher cost
and I just also point out that uh in the
evaluation
the If This Were to pass with that
language it would be an independent
third party which would do the analysis
of sort of the future looking energy
market cost and then you're just
benchmarking each contract against that
so what is the cost and the
term of each one so again trying to be
clear transparent and I think the the
additional language that that analysis
in full uh is required to be provided to
the Public Utilities Commission as part
of a petition for approval that all
parties could review again it it feels
uh like a strong
transparent an appropriate process and I
appreciated Mrs Connor's clarification
that the utilities had actually been the
entities that had issues these rfps in
the past in Massachusetts
so you wouldn't be you would be in favor
of the language suggested by
representative McGee I think it's a
helpful clarification I think it it
provides some additional strength to the
process and uh to Mrs to miss Connor's
uh suggestion of of an application fee
uh to go along with it I think that's an
interesting concept I want to obviously
think it through a little bit more but
uh you know there's potentially some
some value in that for sure
do you think that language would be
redundant to the language and
section four that has the department of
energy also uh hiring Consultants
presumably independent third-party
Consultants to evaluate the RFB is it
redundant
um
so I I do not think that it's redundant
and I will let obviously the department
speak for itself as well as the OCA
about how they would engage in this
process but I think that you know
obviously the utilities are one party
we're going to engage an independent
consultant to do an analysis
the Public Utilities Commission excuse
me the consumer Advocate and the
department of energy will be additional
parties providing rigor and review to
this process uh both at the front end of
the development of the RFP but also when
the utilities uh if they receive
appropriate responses back petitioned
for approval by the commission you'll
now have those uh as they are today
those agencies being a party to those uh
filings and obviously they can provide
review and rigor and I presume you know
it is very common for them to hire
Consultants to to assist in that so it's
really having multiple set of eyes
looking at as was pointed out uh
significant contracts that represent a
long-term commitment
question Mr Corman representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman
so
what I'm seeing is the prospect of doe
hiring an independent third party and
then the utilities hiring an independent
third party
um presumably two different independent
third parties do you foresee any problem
in finding
two independent third parties who are
truly independent of each other and each
competent to do these analyzes
so I I don't believe so
um I think there are different
consulting firms that specialize in this
um and I I would suggest that the the
role of each are are slightly different
um so one right now the language is that
the department May hire Consultants to
Aid in the development of the RFP so
that's putting together the the actual
request for proposal language that goes
out
um so then
the RFP gets issued
um responses come back the utilities
receive those responses the utilities
engage in independent third party to
conduct a cost-benefit analysis of those
responses prior to submission to the
commission for uh approval so it's it's
sort of different steps in the process a
different venue but I think it all adds
strength to the process
well
those are good points but we have to be
careful to avoid paralysis by analysis
um we can have these rfps evaluated
before they're issued we can have them
evaluated after they're issued and
eventually you know the process is going
to take so long that people just throw
up their hands and walk away so we have
to be careful but those are good points
Mr Phelan
so there was something there that Mr
locata pointed out that I think it Bears
repeating the sections that we are
talking about are about the development
of the RFP itself they are not about the
analysis of the bids or the the sort of
approval process that comes after so
um having an independent third party
look at these things would be a lot more
useful if it's looking at what builds
came forward is the utility acting
prudently those asking those sort of
questions rather than how is the RFP
structured and what are the details of
that
so just clarifying those pieces of the
bill great thank you
okay so we spent close to 15 minutes on
question number one
we have about 20 Questions here so this
is going to be a long day Mr below
thank you oh
there we go I just wanted to add some
information that I think um uh Bears
consideration on this question
um I'm here on behalf of the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire a joint
power agency of 33 jurisdictions within
the state our 32 Municipal members
represent about 22 or more than 22
percent of the state's population
um what I wanted to say is that a couple
things within a year or two we are
expect to become the either the largest
or second largest supplier of
electricity in New Hampshire likely
serving more than half of all default
service customers across the state we
have already contracted for state of the
art uh software as a service and
consulting services to do precisely this
type of evaluation we'll be recovering
those costs from our ratepayers the
company that we've contracted with for
the next three years Ascend analytics
does precisely this type of project
analysis for also sorts of entities
including providing services to ISO New
England New York Power Authority Duke
Energy
amaran as well as a number of them are
sophisticated Community Choice
aggregations in California that use
their power Sim and portfolio planning
software to evaluate competitive
procurements and I just mentioned that
because we will have that capability in
place to help evaluate uh such proposals
and I would just like to suggest that
the door should be open through the puc
process to let other load serving in any
new hampshires for which the utility
would be entering into long-term
obligations on their behalf essentially
for all rate payers to be able to also
evaluate responses to the proposal and
that I I appreciate your point we don't
want uh paralysis by analysis but we're
you know feel that we're a significant
stakeholder and and we already have the
state-of-the-art software and consulting
services to do that type of evaluation
and in fact our own business plan calls
for us as we develop our credit uh uh
investment grade credit rating which is
typically occurs after about three years
of operation to be able to do this kind
of long-term Contracting ourselves on
behalf of our customers
so thank you
thank you quick question are you
suggesting that
there is additional language needed in
the bill to allow
organizations such as your own
to enter into these or to create these
requests for proposals right now it's
restricted to invest around electron
electric distribution utilities
well we're we're no I'm asking for an
opening to be able to help look at
comment on the RFP in the first place
there was a suggestion maybe it maybe
it's in there now that there could be at
least comment on the proposed RFP
language before it goes out but more
importantly uh to be able to uh also do
our own evaluation and be able to enter
that as testimony in the adjudicated
proceeding we're not necessarily opposed
to this concept of this common
Contracting for everyone
um but we are concerned that it results
in the the best most appropriate
projects be selected and I realize that
may require non-disclosure agreements
and things like that but that that seems
all all doable when you have a a party
with an interest in the case so I think
I don't have specific language but the
concept is uh to to allow at least a
load serving entities that Supply New
Hampshire businesses and residents and
opportunity to also be involved in the
evaluation of RFP responses
so the legislation already contains the
language
within this period the utilities May
solicit public comment well that's you
permissive do you think that should be
so
yes
in terms of the RFP
process
and and just one comment you know I I
think um I I don't disagree with the
idea that
um uh in in the first instance the
utilities are in a better position than
the department of energy uh for for the
Consulting as has been proposed here I
just Just one thought you know it says
the utilities shall contract with an
independent uh validator if they're the
Contracting party that that vendor is
accountable to them so it's it's a
little tricky to say that they'd be
truly independent because
because the utility would be directing
them as a consultant working on behalf
of the utility so I'm just I'm just not
sure quite how
how you make it independent I think doe
and OCA can hire an independent
validator because because they don't
have their only stake is in looking for
the public good in the consumer interest
so the language we're talking about does
apply to the uh the department and the
office of the consumer Advocate not to
the utilities okay so okay thanks for
that clarification let's move on to
another question
um so that we can have some hope of
getting through the day here without
wearing everybody out
next question is about the 20-year
Horizon
for contracts under this legislation we
actually have two uh questions about
this
one is is a 20-year Horizon the right
length of time for contracts for
cost-effective deals
does a long-term contract help or hurt
the deal making and the current energy
spot Market would anybody like to
comment on that question
I believe the language in the in the
legislation says up to 20 years doesn't
specify 20 years but can be as long as
20 years Mr Phelan
that was precisely my point that the the
language is for up to 20 years we do not
know the most effective length of
contract going into this so it is
certainly possible that a 10-year
contract uh incense the the kind of
resources that can Bill uh bit into this
and and provide energy through this we
just don't know that right now so 20
years is a pretty standard term for a
long-term power contract and we're not
looking to limit our options based on
the contract length
thank you anybody else want to comment
on that
uh yes Sam Evans Brown
uh thank you for the opportunity I just
wanted to state that what we have heard
from developers across the board is that
generally speaking when it comes to cost
of capital that a longer contract almost
universally results in lower cost
financing and so there's a direct
correlation between longer term
contracts and lower lower cost financing
which as we laid out in our testimony on
this bill is can be a large driver of
the cost of the the levelized cost of
energy for for high Capital cost
projects so I would encourage the
committee not to reduce the length and
as Mr Phalen laid out if a 10-year
contract is more is more cost effective
developers are free to bid that in as
part of the RFP
great thank you
okay representative Thomas
thank you so I just have one question
and and I don't know the answer to this
but
it could be up to 20-year contract
we have a society right now that we seem
to change things every week things
change very quickly up and down spikes
and drops and so forth
what can be done to ensure that when you
do this contract
20 years in today's time is a lifetime
things can change in five years it could
change for the worse how do you do
something where you don't get trapped
into a 20-year nightmare that's that's
my question is isn't there any concern
over that
anyone anyone have a comment on that
question
our consumer Advocate Mr Grace
okay I can't resist taking up the bait
first of all let me just say I I support
Senate Bill 54 I I didn't testify at
last week's hearing but and I'm eager to
do whatever the subcommittee in the
committee feels is necessary to make the
bill as good as it can be so that it can
be sent to the governor for his
signature uh representative Thomas I
think the answer to your question to be
frank is nothing I mean that's that is
the rub right that's that the whole idea
of a 20-year contract is you lock in an
obligation for 20 years that gives the
developer the certainty that it needs is
Mr Evans Brown just pointed out to
invest the capital and borrow the money
that it needs to move forward but it
locks ultimately the rate payers in for
that period and and if if you're worried
about the potential adverse consequences
of that uh I I commend you because that
that's a legitimate issue but you know
it's always that trade-off between
certainty and uh and risk I guess I mean
and and I think ultimately we need a mix
of long-term and short-term commitments
so that we do our best to uh hedge all
of our risks I hope that's a somewhat
helpful answer
you want to follow it go ahead thanks
yeah um and I and I agree my my concern
is focused on the fact that
that's like a old way of doing business
uh things that you know the contracts
have been that way for a long time we're
entering a period time now where things
are changing quickly and the the
paradigms are are being mixed and
changed and wrapped around and so I'm
just kind of curious if there's any if
there's a new way of thinking of how we
can get these things done like that I
just don't want to see as as technology
changes as it will change within the
next couple of five years I don't want
to see us get involved in a 20-year
contract where that where now we're
dealing with old old technology in
today's terms two years is old so that
that was my concern
you have a comment down to that uh I I
share that concern but I I guess we
can't we we can't invent a new flavor of
contract law uh technological change has
always been a reality uh we are locked
into certain Technologies now that we
continue to rely on it is a problem and
I I guess I I'm
uh my perspective on that is that as we
confront more and more uncertainty the
things that we can do to hedge against
those uncertainties become in a sense
more and more desirable
thank you appreciate that a related
question
about limits
is why was the limitation of 2 million
megawatt hours imposed in this
legislation what factors were considered
in defining this limitation does anybody
have any comment on that
Mr Phelan
sure so the the Department's goal in the
2 million megawatt hour
limit was to limit how how much
out-of-market actions we are taking
because I think it's it's important to
know that
this represents a a change in New
Hampshire's state policy
so to to sort of to speak about the ways
that things have been done for the past
20 years uh New Hampshire has
participated in a Wholesale Electric
markets and used those to drive cost
decisions to drive investment decisions
in the region this bill is a recognition
of the limits of those markets that is
not to say that the markets themselves
are
unjust to use a regulatory term but the
that this 20 hedge is recognizing that
sometimes these markets produce outcomes
that hurt rate payers and really get to
the get to the heart of pocketbooks so
the this is aimed at 20 of New
Hampshire's load we chose that because
it represents and balance between
hedging and fully Contracting
so the two million megawatt hours
represents 20 percent of the state's
load
and said roughly does that
answer the committee's questions
subcommittee's questions about that
issue
okay
all right let's move on so we had
questions the next question actually
came from both of our lists
and this question is can we require
performance incentives
from these ppas
so that uh if if reliability is one of
the goals of of these ppas should they
include some kind of a penalty for
non-performance
anybody have a
a potential ad you want to elaborate on
the question representative McGee
well
um I know it was on both of our lists as
you said so I um actually have some
language that I was working trying to
figure out where it would be inserted
into the bill
um on that and what basically it comes
down to is sharing the risk
um away from just the the rate payer and
sharing that risk with performance
incentives for meeting projections
and on the generator side penalties for
non-performance during Peak demand
periods to protect rate payers from
demand price spikes and to promote you
know delivery of reliable service so I
know that those are both common parts of
purchase power agreements I don't know
anything about them I don't purport to
be an expert but I thought we could
include language
I I added it to
letter e under number three which is
also in that section two of request for
proposal so I don't have the numbers on
my version that I was editing so I can
point you
have a clean coffee I can just
thanks
okay point you to the
so were you proposing to add this
language to the RFP itself
right before section four yeah here
right there yep so it would be on line
nine page three
uh letter e
so it would say any other factors
necessary to determine whether the
agreement is just unreasonable and in
the public interest such as does the
contract contain performance incentives
for meeting cost projections and
Generator penalties for non-performance
during Peak demand periods to protect
rate payers from demand price spikes and
promote delivery of reliable service
so it's just uh sort of an add-on of any
other factors that we might want to
consider but I think if again if the
goal is to try and make sure that the
ratepayer doesn't Bear all the risk for
um any deviation from the performance in
the contract and the then the
performance metrics positive and
negative have to be shared between
um
between the utility the distribution
utility and the generators who are
responsible for the supply
so essentially this would be a
requirement
for the commission to investigate as it
was reviewing the agreements under this
section for me the easiest thing to do
was add it under any other factors
necessary because I didn't know where
else to put it logically but
um I already sent this over to OLS so
there should be a you know a copy of an
unapproved Amendment which we can
circulate to our group hopefully before
the end of our
session today
incorporating just this change or others
do um well the other ones we discussed
so
um okay I know the hardest part is to
figure out how to amend the actual
Amendment with changes so I went in and
tried to work on it within within the
bill so we would have some language
because I thought it would make it
easier
okay any comments on the suggested
language Ms Connors
thank you I would recommend striking the
word Peak and here's why I think that
the performance obligation should be for
any hour of any day and there's a good
reason for that as you may be familiar
ISO New England and its wholesale
electricity Market has a capacity a
capacity market and so when you in that
capacity Market is there to make sure
that resources that accept money from
ratepayers perform whenever and however
the iso calls to dispatch they're and if
you fail to perform under the capacity
obligation the generator or the whatever
the resource is
pays a penalty if it doesn't show up
the conditions that have triggered that
we've only had two conditions since the
iso initiated paper performance in 2015
or so the iso has only seen two
circumstances when paper performance was
triggered both of those were on holidays
one was on Labor Day weekend when a
there was a fault on the system a large
generator in Boston tripped offline most
of us were at a barbecue right that was
the first paid performance in history
the second was on Christmas Eve or the
sixth day of Hanukkah is someone
recently reminded me of 2022 and most of
us were not paying attention to our ISO
New England apps I think as we see the
grid changing sort of the point you were
making before representative Thomas
we're seeing Behavior patterns change
the the proliferation of solar across
New England is totally changing load
shapes and I think that it's important
to realize that as the technology
changes the load shapes are changing and
when we historically have expect did
tight conditions and the grid is not a
predictor for the future and so I think
it's appropriate to consider the peak
because so many charges are the the
utility customers are exposed to so many
charges related to the peak but the risk
to the rate Pairs and the risk to us
just as end users is not limited to the
peak so I would just strike Peak say if
we expect you to perform and especially
if the iso is calling for you to perform
you got to perform and that moves the
risk away from the rate Pairs and onto
the generator and the other generators
that are in the market thank you
okay
good
all right Mr chairman yeah Mr
representative Summers
um so I know I made it well known the
other day when we heard the uh the
public hearing on this about the risk of
the rate payers and how I was concerned
about that and looking at this
particularly these two questions I'm
after reading the bill through and I was
talking about equal skin in the game
looking at page three line 13 if we were
able to change that may to a shell
so that the
an investor-owned electric distribution
utility shall sell such purchase energy
and environmental attributes in the
wholesale Market in the manner to
minimize costs and maximize benefits to
rates pairs I believe that would put
scan the game on both sides but I'd like
to know your opinion on that thanks
you know that's a complex one and I know
it's really important to the utility and
to community power
um and so I I don't you know that my
concern I'm here representing the
generators that are already in the
market so for us this is 20 of the
market that we can no longer compete for
and so that's my skin in the game in
that regard I will say when it comes to
energy Arbitrage it's really complicated
I use in my former job I I worked at ISO
New England and one of my territories is
in Vermont which you guys know is all
long-term contracts and there have been
changes to Market rules that have just
thrown their contracts upside down and
so I think it can I think that they're I
think it's very risky to prescribe how
and basically the utility should be an
energy broker on behalf of end users I
think maybe permissive and I'll leave it
to um others but you know permissive
language that maximizes the the benefit
to the rate payer might be the best way
to go but again that's really for
Community power and competitive
suppliers who are essentially energy
trading desks I mean a lot of these
companies are arbitraging in
multi-billion dollar markets on behalf
of the rate pairs so from the point of
view of the from the generators it's
it's immaterial but I I do think we
observe complex very complex markets and
prescriptive I would I would be per
I'll defer
okay Mr locata actually has a comment
with regard to this question
thank you uh I was actually asked this
uh same question if eversource supported
that change from the May to a show I
think by representative Wendy Thomas and
just to reiterate we are fine with that
change we understand
um the concern that uh I believe
Community power has stated but others as
well that the utilities could kind of
shift back and forth yeah maybe we will
use it for default service and then if
pricing goes a different way we'll sell
it into the market
um that's certainly not our intent uh
our intent would be we would make a
filing and that is how we would uh for
cost recovery going forward so changing
that from a May to a shall uh I think we
certainly don't object to and
um just on the
um pay per performance language uh you
know representative McGee had mentioned
that to me and
um I I think there's certainly some
value in that obviously you won't be
careful and cautious with the language
that you use you don't want to
um uh inadvertently uh you know cause an
issue I think uh Miss Connor's actually
made a good point about uh the reference
to Peak and whether that was appropriate
so just to say interesting concept and
it's I think it's worthy of additional
thought and maybe some review of the
language
okay to follow along on
representative Summers question about
how do we treat rate payers
with regard to cost recovery
I have a question here that says should
the method of utility cost recovery for
customer charges be specified in statute
for example rate design versus stranded
cost recovery right now all it says all
the legislation says is that
credit or charge all distribution rate
payers the difference between the
agreement payments and proceeds through
a uniform fully reconciling annual
Factor
in rates
do we need more elaboration on exactly
how that cost recovery goes anybody have
a opinion about that Mr below
I do
um I I would suggest that well a couple
things one is
um this is a long-term hedge it's a
physical hedge of saying we're going to
contract for the output of some new
generation resource and uh that's on
behalf of all rate payers so it does
make sense to recover if the benefit if
we structure so the benefits we've got
all rate payers
um or the net costs if it ends up 10
years out a new technology like modular
nuclear comes along and it's much
cheaper than we can find that we've
contracted for something that's too
expensive and we just have to live with
it because that was our hedge uh you
know back in 2024.
um but that being said I I think it's
important not to get this conflated with
distribution cost
um so I would suggest some direction
that might make sense is that this be in
a assuming a contract is entered into uh
that it be recovered as sort of a common
supply cost that's applied to all rate
payers uh but it maybe has its own line
item that goes along with Supply but
it's the it's the common
hedge that was you know Common Supply
hedge I'm not sure exactly what you call
it but I don't think it makes sense to
have it go into a distribution rate for
instance one other thought on that is
there is a possibility that the utility
a utility we go through this whole
process expend a fair amount of money to
to do the RFP the evaluation the
regulatory process and then it gets
turned down and then what happens so so
one thing that could be said in the
statute is that all these costs rather
than just saying
they're instantly recovered from
everyone that they become a regulatory
asset that the utility accrues these as
a regulatory asset if if it is a
contract goes forward those costs get
approved as part of the the supply
contract so it's part of that supply
cost
um or if it's not approved then that be
able to be recovered through the
stranded cost recovery charge which all
the utilities still have because that's
effectively what it would be would be an
expense that they incurred uh and and it
and it got stranded because there was no
Revenue stream to pay for it and so it
goes into stranded cost recovery that
those are my main thoughts
question Mr representative Corman right
so so just to be clear you're you're
suggesting that the costs not go into
the distribution costs at all that they
be charged separately either through the
energy supply cost for the rate payers
who are getting default service
or as a stranded cost well no for for
all so if if like if it was Community
power is your supplier
there's an additional charge or credit
on your bill that's the common Supply
component for this 20 percent although
it may or may not be 20 of our our load
at that point but but but it would be
proportioned out to everyone based on
kilowatt hours delivered so it is just
based on the the amount of power
distributed to everyone
obviously it's by utility because this
is not actually Statewide it's utility
by utility where this may or may not
occur
okay representative McGee so I think
we're some of the questioning is coming
in is that we heard from various folks
that there was a concern that folks who
were not on default service would also
be on the line for this distribution
charge and so I think we were I also was
trying to throw in nuanced language
um when I spoke with Mr locata about
that concept and so can you just say
something about that because it's I took
notes on what you were saying and it
sounds like
um you're just saying if it is not
um
if it is not pulled into the
distribution charge which would be
um
an incongruent way to represent it on
the bill right yeah so everyone sort of
benefits from that Supply being used on
the system and everybody so can you just
I mean that's the proponents uh position
on the bill that this this is
in part because
um most
um the way
most power supplied through through
competitive suppliers or the utility
default Services is somewhat short term
it might go out three or four or five
years but my understanding is that for
some projects
for example it's you know I think it's
worth asking what kind of projects might
qualify in this and it seems like the
two major ones are offshore wind
which may not always perform at
precisely at the peak but we know that I
think the modeling shows that does
offshore it produces on a daily basis
because there's always some wind
offshore and and including in the
wintertime so that's one possible Source
another is a long-term contract maybe
with Hydro Quebec which might involve
transmission upgrades
um in in in those cases even the
transmission upgrades to connect New
Generation that would also include some
of the you know offshore wind for
instance uh it is appropriate that those
get rolled into that price because the
policy is long then if New Generation
needs to interconnect you include that
interconnection cost for that particular
unit you know in their cost
um uh so so you know in some sense it
might be
it might make be nice if this was as the
bill originally imagined uh uh
introduced uh confined to default
service rate payers but but but the
reality is that's an unknown quantity
and I understand why eversource wouldn't
want to do this just for default service
customers
um so if it's structured so that
benefits or net costs flow to everyone
then then it makes sense not to confine
it to that there is something else I
want to mention at some point I don't
know if it's among your questions but
um I I do support sort of moving the May
to Shell
um well just just slow down a second
here
um in the existing bill it does say that
the utility shall recover any privilege
incurred cost related to complying with
the section through distribution rates
so it all it does say distribution rates
specifically I think the commission
should even be given more leeway
um and they could be given direction
that they can recover it through
non-by-passable charge but whether that
charge you know uh it doesn't it doesn't
make sense that it needs to be hidden so
to speak in the distribution rate
because it is a supply hedge that's one
thought the other thought is back on
your previous questions about Shell
versus May uh purchased energy and any
environmental attributes into the
wholesale Market
the point I want to mention and and I we
I can come back to this later if it's
one of your questions is that there is
not really a wholesale Market certainly
not one run by ISO New England for
renewable energy credits for uh
environmental attributes my
understanding is that most wrecks get
traded through private Brokers or
private trading desks which are not
transparent
um so
it's it's and in fact when the utilities
either purchase wrecks or when they
project the cost of future wrecks such
as Unitil did in their proposal for 4.99
megawatt solar array uh to be treated as
a load reducer they those those are not
disclosed those are considered uh
competitively sensitive data so my
concern is how will we know how what
does it mean to sell wrecks into the
wholesale Market when there it just
means it's being sold at wholesale and I
want to suggest something that I think
might make sense because if we end up
with a project that produces wrecks like
offshore Windwood why not just take all
the wrecks produced over the course of a
calendar year and a portion the actual
wrecks out to all load serving entities
in New Hampshire in proportion to the
total load served by that entity over
the same calendar year this is possible
because like for instance for this
calendar year year 2023
Rex can still be procured after the
first of next year and they don't get
reported and sort of they don't have to
be settled and reported until July 1st
of the following year so there would be
actually have time to know what the
wrecks produced by the project were and
a portion amount to all load-serving
entities in proportion to the load and
then they can use those either for
compliance or if they don't need them
they can sell them and and use that to
offset other costs for supplying those
cost customers but it would be a way to
minimize cost because if you're selling
them at wholesale through a broker or
trading desk there's going to be
significant transaction costs which sort
of devalue those wrecks and to the
extent we have a PPA that buys Rex for
the next 20 years why not deliver those
wrecks directly back to New Hampshire uh
rate payers you know indirectly through
the load serving entity that otherwise
has to acquire them for those rate
payers
interesting idea it's a fairly
significant expansion of this build so
maybe we would want to consider that as
a separate bill at a later time maybe I
don't know
um anybody else have any comment on that
concept or or the concept of
making
cost recovery more transparent
either of those Mr locata
I I appreciate Mr below's comments and I
think there are sort of two different
sections of the bill that are getting
referenced there that that do two
different things so
um
the
on page three lines 18 and 19 credit or
charge all distribution rate payers the
difference between the agreement
payments and proceeds through uniform
fully reconciling annual factor in rates
um there's a reference to all
distribution rate payers there but that
doesn't necessarily at least in our mind
mean that they would be recovered
through the distribution charge on
customers bills uh quite frankly our
assumption is that these would be
treated as some of the other long-term
contracts that the company currently has
which are recovered through separately
through the stranded cost recovery
charge so it would be a separate item or
in this random cost recovery charge so
not sort of just buried in distribution
rates uh which pay for the distribution
system and are separate from from
supplies so uh and the
reference to
um on page two lines 25 through 26
that's C
where it says electric distribution
utilities shall recover any prudently
incurred cost related to complying with
this section through distribution rates
um that was simply talking about the
actual administration of the RFP uh so
running the process and then selecting
uh selecting you know the appropriate
response and filing that with with the
commission so not the entirety of if a
PPA is approved flowing that through so
just sort of two different sections
doing two different things and I think
our uh assumption uh is that the
commission would treat this as it has in
the past other long-term contracts that
that do not flow in the distribution
rate itself so distribution rates
distribution rate uh it's a slight
difference there
um so I think that was the root of the
question
should it be explicitly stated here
that
cost recovery would come via stranded
cost recovery charges rather than some
other method
if that's going to be the method you
assumed would be used should that be
stated
we would have no objection to that if it
was the committee's preference
okay thank you anybody else have any
comment on that question
Mr cormer representative Carmen thank
you
so
when when I look at that that language
on lines 26 and 27 of page two it talks
about complying with this section
so I just want to make sure that we're
talking about the same thing when we say
this section that's section Roman
numeral one of the language in the bill
as opposed to
the section of the bill that starts on
line 16 of page one where it says two
new section purchase power agreements
because that encompasses a whole lot
more than just Roman numeral one yes so
our view
is that lines 25 and 26.
when it refers to this section
um I'm just making sure I'm
tying the two sections together as you
said
um
is talking about the issuance and
evaluation of the rfps
so and that is I believe contained
within section one uh of the bill and
then thereafter the actual cost or
credit uh which is obviously the ideal
uh outcome of the of the power purchase
Agreements are subject to the cost
recovery mechanisms uh at the end of the
bill so so that is you're reading
is matches our reading as well good
thank you
Mr below
that that may be the intent but
technically I think section in a law
refers to the entirety of section
11 uh starting on page six line 16 of
page one I think everything in here is
the section Roman one uh concerning rfps
I think is technically considered a
paragraph and all these other things are
sub-paragraphs of the section so you may
want to say this paragraph if it's
intended only for Roman one or otherwise
clarified because section I think means
the whole uh Roman 11. I'm not uh Arabic
11. I tend to agree with you I think
that's the way legislative language
works that it refuses to the refers to
the entire
body of Statute
um
delineated by the by the
by The Heading so all right let's move
on to another question then we've
answered
five or six so far
um
let's move to a question of
a suggestion from one of the people who
testified
at the public hearing
I'm not sure that this is actually a
question should we adopt the suggestion
that we replace lines 22 through 25
on page two
with language that says quote
incremental electric energy sources are
the new and additional resources
which as a result of new construction at
sites where energy facilities existed
prior to January 1st 2023 are able to be
provided into the iso regional market
for the first time on or after January
1st 2023.
22 through 25
so the suggestion here is adding some
dates
to this
paragraph
energy
changing the time
yes representative Corman yeah thank you
um yeah so what would be added here
would be just saying uh for the first
time on or after January 1st 2023 and I
believe the intent of the conservation
law Foundation there was to say that
suppose you have a facility that's
already running and producing power and
then it gets added onto
that the interpretation should be that
the incremental resources are only the
part that got added on to or were added
and not the part that was already there
okay anybody out there have a comment on
that suggested language change
Mr Phelan
yeah let's excuse me because this is a
bit on the Fly and I'm not sure that I
fully understand what the changes but
our
our position is that the
additional energy
is what is the is what is defined as
incremental under the current language
that's that's so I'm not
sure what the change
would accomplish
yeah I'll have to admit I'm a little
confused about that one myself
okay let's hear what uh
representative McGee explain please
um actually had that conversation for
what you're saying Mr Phelan
um and uh came to the same conclusion so
all right let's move on then to another
question
you seem to have resolved that one
yes Miss Hatfield can you uh elucidate
on what
the original suggestion was
thank you Meredith Hatfield for The
Nature Conservancy I think the concern
was to try to be clear so that if for
example
um the gas plant in Londonderry was able
to add a megawatt and then bid that in
would we want to the entire entire plant
to be able to get a PPA for all of its
output and I'm not sure if this is clear
that it doesn't mean that they could bid
all of their output in for example so
you want to restrict it to their
incremental
New Generation output not their existing
I thought that was the intent of the of
the proposal was to to only allow the
incremental not allow an entire facility
if it added some incremental to then be
able to bid in all of the output
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman you know as I read
the language that's here
it's talking about the result of the new
construction is capable of providing
additional energy I think it does
exactly what you're talking about I
don't know see why there's any need for
uh additional words to say the same
thing
thank you yeah we may be talking about a
legal hair split here
I don't know okay all right let's move
on
uh seeing no further comments on that
here's a question what kind of rate
payer protections can the bill provide
for joint utility ppas particularly
those that involve out-of-state
utilities
I think the Genesis of that question is
do we in New Hampshire
want to expose ourselves to
contracts that involve
entities from other states which may
have different laws may have different
goals may have different issues
and if that is the case are there any
protections we can build in to these
ppas
to protect New Hampshire ratepayers
anybody have a
Mr locata
thank you
so I I know
um
this provision was uh an important one
to Senator Waters and he I believe he
spoke to it
um I would just say that regardless of
whether the utilities uh
uh enter into sort of a a joint
solicitation with utilities outside of
New Hampshire or not
this is the governing statute
it has to whatever response PPA we get
back has to conform to to New Hampshire
law and New Hampshire statute so it
would have to
win on you know sort of the criteria in
New Hampshire that we have which is uh
contained you know a through e on page
three what the um uh
what the Public Utilities Commission
will be evaluating so if a another
um
State pulled in environmental
considerations or Economic Development
considerations
that would be part of their evaluation
that could not be part of our evaluation
so
um you know I I think it would be very
and I believe I said this to Senator
water is very challenging for a utility
to engage in a joint multi-state
procurement
um uh using this statute but I again I
know that that was something he wanted
to keep the door open so just to be
clear though
um it is this law that would govern New
Hampshire's participation in that
representative McGee thank you
um so I think you know when we were
reviewing when I was reviewing language
and uh we look at the legislative
findings and purpose which starts at the
top of the bill
and one of the ways to
um Define
the emphasis or priorities that the
states intends for the moving forward of
these types of utility ppas is under
number three the development of reliable
sources of low-cost I inserted in-state
electricity Supply is critical to
stabilizing and reducing the cost of
electricity in New Hampshire it doesn't
prohibit
um you know cross state ppas if if they
come up it doesn't put you in a straight
jacket but it basically says that
the thing we're trying to solve for is
reliability in state
and I believe you said Mr Lucado that
you didn't have any problem with adding
that um emphasis
yeah that's uh that's fair and I think
um one you know
and I don't know if there are others who
can speak to this uh better than I can
one does have to be careful
um you as I understand it
um
you open yourself up to Legal challenge
if you are just having it sort of an
in-state or in-state preference
procurement uh what we've seen in other
states uh and even if you look at how
the state RPS is structured it is not
limited to to Simply New Hampshire based
um uh generation that it it you run a
sort of Commerce Clause issues uh doing
so so you just want to be very careful
with the references to in state
obviously we want the benefits to flow
in State uh but the I think the
procurement needs to be
open well again this is just a statement
of purpose it's not not part of the
Contracting piece
but
okay
thank you anybody else Ms Connors
I want to um I would like to build a
little bit on what part of what Mr
locata just said as I look think about
the regional perspective I was trying to
think about corollaries in other states
you know how often do our distribution
utilities or the equivalent you know
it's kind of I think of this as actually
novel
um and so when I think of times when
other states have worked together
for the purposes of of an energy
solicitation it has been
um it has been done more through the
transmission system than through the
distribution system for example
Massachusetts Connecticut and Rhode
Island issued an RFP I think they
literally called it the Tri-State RFP it
was about five years ago in which they
said they wanted to join together to
procure transmission to access wind
and the reason they tend to do it that
way is because it isn't State
jurisdictional when you start working
with other states and electrons move at
the speed of light minus line loss and
friction so I do I I
apologize for the halting manner in
which I'm speaking because this is a
little bit novel and the way I'm
thinking about it but it isn't to build
on what Mr locata said when you start
saying out of state it starts to trigger
other considerations that might be
larger than what the state can control
you may have an
the intent may be to work with other
states but it I think that this is
something that may warrant
um further consideration if you don't
want to get tripped up on some of the
issues Mike mentioned
I think it goes to a different part of
the bill when you start going outside
your borders thank you
Mr Phelan
yeah so the the department would have
serious concerns with adding that
in-state language to the statement of
purpose
um partially because
simply the the Electric System is not an
in-state
machine and there are plenty of
reliability benefits that come from
resources that are outside of the State
of New Hampshire that's why we're
connected to uh Interstate grid
um and really we have concerns about
placing an in-state requirement in
general because we want the best deal
for ratepayers we we don't want this to
be a protectionism sort of thing we want
low-cost reliable power and that that's
the priority that may be served by an
NCAA generator it may not we we don't
want to limit this procurement to
in-state resources
good point okay
reducing the cost of electricity of
which part of the reason was that we had
to import more expensive fuel right okay
understood we get we get your point all
right let's move on new question
how does allowing the utilities to do
anything other than sell procured Supply
into the wholesale Market to get the
best rate
square with deregulated utilities
controlling generation assets what
guardrails are needed to avoid unlimited
state-sanctioned rate payer subsidies
in a free market
a broad question admittedly but you want
to elaborate representative McGee
I think the shell May on selling into
the wholesale Market kind of addresses
that the idea that you know if the
energy that's procured is then put onto
the market so that anyone can bid on it
then
it's it's solved so
um that's I don't know how much more
discussion there has to be okay did you
want to comment Mr locata or did
that comment by representative McGee
address
okay
all right
we'll move on then next question comes
from over here
should utilities be allowed to earn a
profit just for signing a PPA since the
PPA constitutes a debt on their balance
sheet until its conclusion
Mr locata
um in other jurisdictions the utilities
do earn a percentage of the total value
of the contract
that is not included in this legislation
there is no ability for the utilities to
earn an Adder on this
now the question is should it
well I I can tell you what the utilities
might like but I think that would
jeopardize passage of the bill
well obviously the whole point of this
legislation is to incent incentivize
create creation of these ppas so the
question is
will this be a sweetener that would
help encourage utilities to seriously
consider entering into these ppas
um
I I think that's a fair question
right now the legislation is is truly
enabling there is no requirement for the
utilities to
issue the rfps and then subsequently
enter into the ppas
would it be a sweetener an enticement to
do that yes uh I I think that's a fair
statement that said
um again I I think
uh that would jeopardize passage of the
bill and I think that the utilities
um interest in this is to
develop new resources to reduce
long-term costs for customers uh you
know ultimately it's it's the utilities
name on the bill uh that we get the sort
of negative response when electric rates
double even if it's something outside of
our control so I I appreciate the
question but again uh we are comfortable
with the legislation uh you know as
passed by the Senate uh and uh again I
think that it would be make passage
challenging
Mr Phelan I thought I saw your hand go
up
representative McGee wants to make a
quick comment
yeah I think
um you know my background in business
they say you get the behavior reward
right and I look at getting like a
signing bonus or you know everyone gets
a trophy if you just create a contract
you you get rewarded I don't know that
that's something that the state would
like to incent as much as performance
incentives right putting something in
that actually is related to whether
you're you know sort of delivering on
on what you're being you know enabled to
deliver so that's the way I would review
it is that giving them a percentage just
for signing a contract you know that's
before
that's before any of the um benefits
that we're hoping to derive from it are
actually seen so I think performance
incentives make a little more sense but
that's just me Mr Phelan
sure so the Department's position on
this is is pretty straightforward
there's no risk for the utilities
involved in the outlay of this Capital
so therefore they should not earn a rate
of return on it that's that's our
clear perspective
good solid Point thank you for that
next question
whoops
what effect will long-term procurement
by utilities have on New Hampshire's
burgeoning competitive energy Market
that's an interesting question kind of
open-ended question
I'm not sure it's directly related to
the bill but
um
anybody having a response to that one
Mr Grace
I guess my response is
to reply with a question which is from
the perspective of residential
ratepayers what burgeoning competitive
energy Market
uh and I I don't mean to be glib but my
counterparts in Massachusetts and Maine
have now both commissioned deeply uh
detailed studies that demonstrate that
residential utility customers have not
benefited and in fact have actually
arguably been harmed by what is
described what that question just
described as the burgeoning competitive
market
Mr below might have an answer to that
question well he might answer in terms
of the Community power aggregation
uh movement and I guess well I'd be
curious to hear what he has to say about
that too
all right did you have anything else
representative McGee that you wanted to
uncover with this question
I I think that the point of the question
was that we just enabled the community
power coalition to create some
competition in the New Hampshire energy
market and we're not really sure how
it's what kind of you know how it's
going to play out but we know that
people have been
moving toward it even my town at town
meeting this year in March decided to
move forward and try and you know get
under contract by next year so I guess
the idea is do we know what we're doing
in terms of how that will impact taking
20 percent of the load for New Hampshire
and
um
you know doing what we're doing
do we understand how that's going to
affect the rest of the market and I just
thought if anybody could help answer
that that would be a good thing to know
okay
Mr below do you have a response
um well if it's
our original concern with the bill is it
was passed by the Senate is it at least
on paper created an opportunity for
potential subsidy of utility default
service
changing that made a shell at least with
regard to the energy portion uh you know
tends to neutralize that problem
um our own we've adopted a portfolio
risk management policy and regulations
and our own policies dual it would allow
us to do this kind of long-term hedge at
this sort of 20 level of our load
um
so I I guess if if if it's
if it's structured in a way uh that that
it's clear that um benefits and costs uh
pass through to all rate payers
proportional to their load uh then then
it's somewhat and it's potentially a
neutral effect I think the bigger
question is it's it is putting the
distribution utilities back in to the
business of major power procurement
decisions and we have intentionally
designed Community power both through
legislation and rules and our own RFP
and procurement of vendor Partners
um to be able to perform this kind of
service but not at risk to other rate
payers and even our own rate payers
would be risk would be limited because
if we end up making a Bad Bet and you
know in 10 years our Hedges out of the
money uh then then
um you know customers are always free to
leave to go back to utility default
service or another competitive supplier
which is just why I think it's so
important to have the the the
you know a really good evaluation up
front and and you know part of the
software we've contracted for it is
stochastic modeling it's based on a
model of the entire U.S energy uh system
every bulk generator in the whole
country all those in New England are
part of the model so it can model
hundreds or thousands of different
future scenarios with all the different
possible variables and start giving us a
probabilistic outcome of whether
particular uh hedge is
um likely to to to prove worthwhile or
or not
um
so
so that so I you know I I still kind of
go back to that Renewable Energy Credit
concern because if this ends up being
offshore wind or something else can
produce wrecks two million wrecks per
year is a lot and if those all go
through a broker
that's that's that's not going to
produce the most value for New Hampshire
rate payers so what I'm saying if if
we're Contracting a price for Rex that's
part of a deal then then why not provide
those wrecks directly to all the loan
serving entities in proportion to their
load because that would help mitigate
the potential damage I I mean my concern
is that we'd be out there need more us
because we we offer 50 100 renewable
we'll want more wrecks than the minimum
compliance because because uh some rate
payers want that higher renewable
content and if if we're getting the if
we're paying say 20 a rack for the next
um 20 years uh but then those are sold
through a broker it could end up costing
us 25 to buy them and we're only getting
you know and we're only getting 20
in the Brokers skimming that difference
you know in the process or it's not
really skimming it's they provide a
service by reselling but why not just
give those wrecks directly so that I'm
just just suggesting that one change
could be of significant financial
benefit and maybe it's worth trying to
think through in the next week a way
that would allow the puc to consider
that decision if if it you're not ready
to put into legislation at this point
okay that's a second bite of that apple
and uh
we're we're no it's okay I'm just saying
that it's it's it's it's it's it's
worthy of thinking about definitely
worthy of thinking about and it is kind
of a big change but maybe uh it would be
an important enough change to seriously
consider
for this uh
for any amendment that we might
end up generating all right let's talk
about another question here that
to me seems sort of like the elephant in
the room that nobody has talked about
yet
and that is
should only knew or incremental electric
energy sources be considered for these
ppas or
would there be room for existing
base load renewable sources
and Mr Phelan has an immediate answer to
that question
uh that the end of that question
complicated things a a little bit I'll
just say that we are are not looking to
restrict to any subset of technology
types at the end of the question talked
about uh existing base load renewable
resources
um we are in opposition to any change
that
specifies the technology type that would
be eligible for this procurement as to
new or existing more generally part of
the objective of this is that New
England has a building new things
problem and there is a historic
opposition to building anything even
you know local opposition to for
environmental concerns has not stopped
large non-carbon projects from being
stopped in their tracks
in in general New England needs to build
more things in order to provide the
reliable service that our ratepayers
need
so new only is an important part of this
legislation for the Department of energy
okay
what if it was existing base load
resources didn't specify renewable
I'll follow with that we
another reason for not wanting existing
resources is that we do not want to hook
rate payers put rate pairs on the hook
for the last years of a deteriorating
resource so they're
are a lot of Market changes going on in
New England and with that a lot of
resources that may be at risk of
retirement
we don't want those resources hanging
around as an albatross on our ratepayers
next so so
that's another reason why we oppose
including existing in these bills
okay great thank you
all right another question here how can
we help ensure that SB 54 results in a
win for rate payers and for the state's
energy economy
anybody have a yeah Mr stock has a
thought about that question
if you want to answer the prior question
that's okay too okay
no you didn't
this is a pretty informal process and
and I'm trying to accommodate everybody
because our goal here is to get all the
ideas on the table that can make this
bill as
the best build that it can possibly be
and be acceptable to everybody too sure
and I and and I appreciate that and and
I and I appreciate the informal aspect
of this and I guess I did want to speak
to the to the existing question which
was the prior question and you know as a
as someone who represents existing power
plants that are base loaded that are
base load facilities I guess when I look
at the
kind of the objectives of this bill and
as I heard earlier today
um one of the major one of the major
objectives is to find the best deal for
the ratepayer here
I think it would be
um you would be remiss not to consider
an existing facility if it's already a
merchant facility in the marketplace
that's out there it and perhaps it does
have a lower Debt Service because it is
an existing facility
um I think
to consider that sure to not consider
that would be remiss if it can provide a
benefit to the rate payer I look at it
and I I appreciate the concern that we
have a quote building problem
but if you try to stimulate construction
and at the same time ignore potential
closures or closures or facilities going
down that could benefit rate payers
I think you're no further ahead
um and it wasn't long ago that we had a
discussion about the Burgess power plant
which In This Very Room and the question
came up and I think it was
representative Wendy Thomas who quite
pointedly said
so what's next
we have a bill a bill here to look at
that contract and try to reopen that
contract and negotiate it and as a we
look at Senate Bill 54 for that facility
and potentially some of the existing
power plants that as an opportunity that
could provide them an OP inability to to
bid into this program and at the same
time continue to operate and provide a
rate payer benefit
the other upside of this is that for a
facility such as that do you really need
20 years you're not looking at a at a
very extended large extended pay down
terms on a on a new contract or trying a
finance package
so perhaps this could also facilitate
some of the some of the thoughts or
discussions that you've had already
about term in trying to do some
structuring of this so that you're not
putting all your eggs into a 20-year
contract maybe you look at a at some
shorter term contracts that could
provide some opportunities for a
facility that's already paid down some
of its debt service already has its
interconnection and some of that
infrastructure already in place already
invested
so I think I think that you know to to
not consider existing
and again I represent a base load
facility so to some of the comments
earlier
um that were raised about performance
Peak versus performance at any time
baseload fits fits that ticket so I I
would say that we would Advocate that
you would consider
looking at this and allowing existing
allowing existing facilities
to say that a rate payer is going to be
saddled with a an old Antiquated
facility I don't think is a true
accurate statement if that facility is
already in the market already a merchant
facility in the marketplace that
facilities out there bidding in
operating if it closes
that facility is not going to be a a
drain on the rape here and if they have
a contract and if they have a contract
with performance standards already baked
into it
you have some assurance that if for some
reason the facility did fail or did go
down there is a performance standard
that can protect the rate payers so
again I I would just Advocate that
existing facilities be considered in
this and again looking at the looking at
the
at the findings and the purpose
and kind of with an eye towards trying
to find the best deal for the rate
payers why not consider an existing
facility
and I will include my comments at that
and I would be happy to answer questions
well thank you for
giving us your perspective on that
question it's an important question I
think
um
I understand
that a lot of the reason for the
existence of this bill is to stimulate
new investment and and New Generation
we're certainly going to need that
um
but if another purpose of the bill is
reliability and low cost then
it seems to me that it might be
worth asking the question or worth
having the conversation can existing
sources provide some of that so thank
you thank you and and I agree and this
is all in the context of that rate payer
rate payer benefit and if an existing
facility can't provide that rate payer
benefit they don't participate in the
bill
thank you
thank you anybody else have a comment
regarding that question
so I'll go back again to the question
how can we help ensure that SB 54
results in a win for ratepayers and for
the state's energy economy
representative McGee did you want to
elaborate on that question a little bit
I was trying to avoid it um
yeah I think some of the questions that
I sent you were formulated before the
investigation that happened in between
on the question that you just posed I'm
afraid I you know I
very much enjoy Mr Stock's presentation
and
um and I and I understand his point of
view I think the bill is actually
focused on something different with only
a percentage of uh what is the New
Hampshire energy market so
I I would like to see it you know more
narrowly tailored in focused so that it
actually drives towards
you know the goals that have been
identified so we can skip this question
then
I'm just trying to be fair which
question are you pointing to now it's uh
the on page two of your
of the table you sent out it's the
second question down no I'm fine
I want to try to tackle the question of
how can we encourage new resources that
create New Hampshire jobs
anybody have a
question a response to that question
yes Mr below I I would just confirm that
um the bill would run into serious uh
commerce clause for jurisdictional
issues if it if it explicitly tried to
say that the purpose is to favor New
Hampshire generation in some way that's
that's all I'd say
good point
all right
here's a question
does utility procurement via ppas
add risk to wholesale Market
procurements that might increase risk
premiums and thereby increase default
service energies RFP bids
is that a risk
to passing this bill
Mr locata
um you know I think that's a
very fair and astute question and I
think
um
you know not to hang so much on that may
tashao but
taking out
eversource is obviously not a
competitive supplier and I can't speak
for them but from what I understand one
of their concerns when responding to our
solicitations is uncertainty how much of
the load might move away how much do
they have to serve and they build that
risk in and obviously Market volatility
is another big factor in risk and so if
the cost recovery and the the energy is
Flowing outside of default service which
that changed from May to shall would
ensure that it really doesn't impact the
default service solicitation
and you know obviously the one of the
aims of the bill is to reduce Market
volatility by having more reliable
resources in the market so it could help
on that end so I think the bill would
with that made a shall change on how the
energy is flowed uh sort of makes it
neutral I think two competitive
suppliers not that I can speak for them
and the overall purpose being more
reliable uh sources in the market would
be helpful
okay thank you
we're actually uh making some serious
progress a serious dent in this list of
questions
another question from you guys what role
should the public play in the
procurement process
you want to elaborate on what you were
thinking and with that question
yeah I'm just uh I put that in because
we had some comments during the public
hearings about the public having more
input so uh I guess the question is
beyond the role of the consumer Advocate
should there be more public input
okay question about public input Mr
locata
foreign
amendments added in Senate committee was
that the utilities May solicit public
input on the development of the rfps
there has been I think a deal of
discussion about changing that may to a
shall that is also something that we
support and just to give a a very brief
kind of frame of reference as we're
developing these rfps you know obviously
it is very much based on the statute and
we would essentially put out like a
questionnaire to interested stakeholders
in the public of you know questions and
comments to provide feedback as we're in
the development process obviously with
uh per the bill the OCA and consumer
Advocate and so the public there what
we've seen in other jurisdictions tends
to be you know folks who actually might
respond to the RFP who might have
thoughts about the r the the design and
and the like so I I do think that
um there is opportunity for public input
and of course once we go to the Public
Utilities Commission for approval of any
contracts there is an opportunity for
any member of the public or stakeholder
to participate in that so I think that
other May tuition would help strengthen
that process uh as well
great I think we're pretty well agreed
that we're going to make that change
okay
we have another question here about
PP puc approval of these ppas and I know
we have somebody from the puc here today
and I'm not going to put you on the spot
but I'm going to ask the question and if
you want to consider answer answering it
you can should puc approval require
consideration of whether a PPA
disadvantages existing generation
resources that's the question
does
anyone have a response to that question
Ms Connors I think you might have
something yes
if the purpose of the bill is partly
reliability and is partly stability
then I think the impact that any
contract like this on the wholesale
markets and existing power plants Is
Fundamental whether or not it's a good a
good deal
even Massachusetts which has done huge
contracts directs the state
um Department of energy resources to do
a periodic report on what the impact of
the wholesale markets are
and here's the thing if you are worried
about at-risk generators retiring before
you have sufficient capacity online this
is the dream of the transition that
people talk about we will replace the
fossil units with intermittent resources
and we can do this because we will have
so many intermittent resources that we
can make sure that we balance apply and
demand
but by subsidizing those preferred
resources you are putting additional
Financial strain on the existing
resources
if those are retiring prematurely you
will have both a price problem and a
reliability problem
we know that the risks that we're
talking about aren't theoretical we're
seeing existing fossil units retiring
and in some cases being put on
reliability must run contracts to keep
them going
and those are partly why
the prices were so high this winter
because the cost of the reliability must
run contract was so high and the price
of fuel was so uncertain that the the
rfps had to the people who responded to
the default service RFP had to account
for that uncertainty in their bids
so I think that the risks that are
unintended are real both for price and
for reliability and the least we can do
is make sure that we're
asking the question through the
regulatory proceeding
would
requiring the puc to consider the
disadvantages of
ppas on existing resources be covered
by the language on page three line nine
that says
any other factors necessary to determine
whether the agreement is just
and reasonable and in the public
interest with that language cover
the puc considering the effect on
existing resources
the challenge the puc faces I think is
someone who watches these proceedings
and has sympathy for people trying to do
this work which is complex and difficult
is it they're not going to know before
the contract is signed which resources
are going to retire the next year
the impact of the contract will not be
known until the contract is in effect
and so it certainly
um a risk and it's something that
highlights I think something
representative Thomas was asking at the
start of this how long is too long
how big is too big
if you're you know if someone if if ever
Source really does do an RFP for 2
million megawatt hours or the utilities
together do that
the puc will be able to look at what
retirements have taken place between the
time this bill passes and the time the
RFP might take effect but the fact is
the damage will be will be done after
the contract is signed along with the
damage that the other State's rfps are
already doing
so you can put it in and the other thing
is the puc has to factor in all of these
other considerations and they have to
wait they have to weigh a number of
uncertainties that are very hard to know
and that's a very challenging position
that this contract puts them in
because they also have to ask themselves
all these other questions is the price
so cheap that it's worth it you know
they have to balance so many things this
is why we went to a this is why we
stopped letting this is why we stopped
doing this because the risks are so high
and the costs are so long
okay good answer Mr Phelan also would
like to respond to this question
so I think that putting this into the
considerations represents
shifting a policy decision away from the
legislature to what is supposed to be an
adjudicative body so
I mentioned before that this is a policy
change for the State of New Hampshire
the the department of energy is not
traditionally one that has argued for
out-of-market contracts for resources
and we have seen this as a reflection of
Market instability and conditions where
we we simply don't have the resource mix
that we need moving forward
but we are also aware of the negative
impacts of contracts to markets we have
made the determination that on on
balance this is the right choice for New
Hampshire rate payers uh the the puc is
not the appropriate body to decide
whether or not the the state should move
forward with a policy change such as
this that is up to the legislature
okay thank you
the POC will have to pass judgment on
the
contracts though the ppas so we have to
be sure I think that we give them clear
guidelines on how to evaluate those ppas
so that they can
be effective and not
find themselves in the in the midst of a
morass
of conflict about
what's appropriate to approve and what's
not
I have one final question here
should electricity from a PPA be used
only for the utilities default Energy
Service obligation
anybody have a
thought about that question Mr locata
don't know why I kept bringing up my
notebook it's not like I have any
answers in there
um
so uh this is actually something that
the utility uh that eversource uh pushed
back on and and I'll just explain why
that may and chow and the cost recovery
exist as it does so
um default service is is fluid
um customers are not obligated to take
default service they can leave default
service for a competitive supplier they
could leave as part of the municipal
aggregation and so if the utility were
to enter into a long-term contract for a
set amount of electricity and was
required to use that for default service
if a large number of customers left
default service say for municipal
aggregation Community power then
essentially the utility is left with a
you know liability which it cannot
recover we don't have a use for that
energy at that point and we need to sell
it
um in order to to be made whole and so
that is why the the mechanism of
reselling into the market and then uh
having the the credit or charge back to
to all is so important and you know why
the utilities through through this is
actually you know kind of uniquely
positioned because other parties have
that same fluidity issue as Mr Bulow
talked about you know if if Community
power gets too expensive customers could
leave there where through the
distribution rate uh
not the distribution rate but as a
charge to all customers say the stranded
cost recovery charge you know you have
that stability
okay
representative McGee
um the question that I wanted thanks for
taking my question the question that I
wanted to ask was in regard to what
happens with the Rex
because I think that was a legitimate
point for us to consider that we hadn't
heard before and if we are looking to
make the bill as good as possible then
maybe we should have some discussion
around that because it's a large chunk
of the load and uh and those credits
will be substantive so I'm just curious
however source and I feel like you're
speaking for all utilities since I don't
think we have other utilities here I am
not yeah yeah well I guess what I'm
saying is
um is that concept of sort of
um
I don't want to say socializing but you
know democratizing the the credits back
into the system to again further lower
costs for consumers is that something
that you think is a reasonable thing for
us to build in
so I I think Mr Bulow uh raises
uh an interesting point so you know when
reading the bill
as I think we would interpret it as you
know the resale of of those wrecks and
as he pointed out with such a large
volume you're probably selling to a
broker who's then going to resell them
um and I think his concern is well if
you're selling it to a broker who then
is going to resell them there'll be a
charge associated with that
um I think I would just
want to have some thought about
the the solution to that or the flow of
that and how that would look in language
it is I think uh
I don't want to say complicated issue
but but you know you want to get that
language right so I I
I'm not adverse to the concern he's
raising or dismissive of it but you know
just sort of wanted to think that
through obviously with folks uh at
eversource who are smarter about this
than I am
okay we have a turnaround for that
do my best okay thanks all right thanks
well believe it or not we've actually
gone through our entire list of
questions but we're not done
what I'm going to do next is call for a
five minute breather
so that we can all uh
reflect on what we've uh what we've
heard then we're going to come back and
we're going to talk about all this so
please uh return to your seats let's say
by 10 past 11 and we'll resume this work
session but for now we're going to take
a quick break thanks
foreign
can uh
finish this up
in the next uh maybe 45 minutes or so so
that uh
we can make some progress here this
morning so
we have gone through the list of
questions that members of this
subcommittee had generated and we've we
feel we've gotten adequate answers to
those questions
so what I would like to do next
is to find out if there are any other
pieces of information that anybody
sitting out there would like to offer to
us
is uh yes Miss Alex Miss Alexander I
forgotten your last name
spidel
um
I think that would be a reasonable
request and we want to thank you for
being here this morning I hope the
conversation was Illuminating for you
and that you'll be able to take back
some relevant information to discuss
with the other members of the commission
staff
so thank you you you you are free to go
thank you
okay thank you
um
Mr below did you have something you
wanted to add to this conversation
yes it's it's more of a question because
I I don't know about it and I wonder
about it
um which is basically there's a you know
the bill has a limited time frame
understandable but my question is
are there
it might there be value in giving
somebody doe or puc some flexibility to
extend the uh authorization to an agree
entering agreement no later than June 30
20 26.
uh because the question I have is what
kind of projects are in development and
sufficiently mature that they actually
know their transmission interconnection
cost or
um that they can do a firm proposal and
there may be because because obviously
what you'd want is a number of different
projects different Technologies
competing and it could be that there's
just I don't know if this window aligns
when certain projects that might be in
the interconnection queue or get into
the interconnection queue with ISO New
England are mature enough to be able to
compete and so the question is what if
it turns out that there's a bunch of
projects in development and if there was
another six months for response that we
would have a more robust uh
set of responses to an RFP I I guess
that's my open question because I just
don't know enough about where potential
new projects are in in development
a reasonable question thank you for
bringing that to our attention
okay
other information that people might like
to supply Ms Connors
the the committee has appropriously
appropriately been very focused on the
cost of generation
I would think it I think it's important
to note that the bill also sort of gives
a blank check for the cost related to
transmission
with much less attention on that and I
have a Graphic that we use
um that I will be happy to share with
the committee yes we'll do that right
now
go ahead the reality for transmission in
the region is that we've been investing
through the transmission portion of our
bill
in billions billions across the region
of which New Hampshire pays a set
portion of for very important
reliability upgrades and there are
benefits to transmission
I worked at the iso the transmission
operator so I I know very well that
there are benefits to investing in
transmission
however
going forward
we know that we will continue to invest
in billions more in transmission
we are circulating the graphic to
everyone who wants one they're right up
here on the edge of the table
thank you continue Miss Connors
so something for the committee to sort
of contemplate is right now you're
already paying this much more or New
Hampshire's consumers are already paying
incrementally more and we anticipate
according to ISO New England that these
costs will continue to increase
and that those are related to
reliability these are costs that are
hard to control but are necessary for
the reliable operation of the grid
but this bill asked New Hampshire rate
payers to pay additional money on top of
what's already a regional cost for
for reliability and the iso has also
signaled that in addition to the
reliability costs that they will be
funneling some State policies are
driving even more money towards
Transmission in order to interconnect
Renewables and so something the
committee might want to consider is
whether that cost might be something
worth knocking out of the bill
subsidizing the transmission is kind of
a blank check it's a lot of money and it
it will be an incremental cost to the
generation that will also be sitting in
this charge that we're talking about
interesting point
um
any questions about that from well my
representative was jettison from the
bill then who would pay it the developer
who's already making however much
they're making off the contract
which is the status quo
right now if you need if you need a line
for reliability we pay for it New
Hampshire pays its fair share for the
transmission it needs for the reliable
operation of the grid to keep the lights
on and if someone wants to interconnect
a generation project for profit then
they pay for the upgrade
okay good point I'd like to add one more
thing that's not exactly specific to
this chart but it's in The Ether before
you do that representative Doug Thomas
has a question
uh thank you
um yes I'm um
always suspect when I see percentages
like this could you put them into
perspective in terms of
dollar amounts uh from say from a
typical electric bill
oh um
it's dollars I mean transmission is
usually between a third and half of your
bill
a quarter I mean where's the cons could
could we have a done I mean
Transmissions a lot right
but uh but we can get you that in terms
of uh your actual bill like a the
proverbial 650 kilowatt monthly bill uh
are we talking two dollars five dollars
ten dollars for transmission costs can
someone answer that question
um someone with a lot of credibility
behind me says it's it's at least two
two cents per kilowatt hour
so two and a half okay
well I think in my territory was uh the
overall bill was 22 cents a kilowatt
hour so two and a half cents out of 22
cents okay is that really it
says so and we can follow up with the
real numbers
okay thank you now you can make your
other point you know this is really
outside the impact of the markets but
it's something that has been on the top
of a lot of conversation I've been
overhearing which is there's no loss
like a stop gap on the stranded cost for
this and so the way this bill is written
there is absolutely no limit to how much
over market value the rate payers may be
on the hook for and I think with this
this body has
I think picked up wisdom from recent
legislative conversations regarding
over-market ppas something that we
should I would encourage people to
consider is should you put a loss on how
much of a how much loss or how high the
over market cost could be the Berlin
biomass plan I'm sorry to pick on one
because lots of ppas have these problems
but my understanding is the stranded
cost became so high that the legislation
there was legislation to address it I
suggest that there should be a similar
limit to how much the loss can be on the
rate payers for this but again this is
outside the realm of the wholesale
markets but it seemed to be top of mind
for the body how do we protect repairs
what kind of guard rails can we put on
this bill I think identifying how much
pain you're willing for the ratepayers
to take is also worth considering
but you're the ones who are crafting
that
so would you suggest then that page
three of the bill starting at line one
going down to line 10.
that talks about the commission's review
of these ppas
consider
adding a bullet
to encourage the commission to consider
maybe capping
over Market costs in these ppas is that
what you're suggesting I see that as a
way to put risk on the generator to
reduce costs and find efficiencies even
after the contract's been signed and it
protects the ratepayer because if you're
a generator and you don't have a PPA you
are constantly having to look at your
turbines looking at your at the training
of your of your staff look at your your
ongoing operating expenses and you try
to find efficiencies because someone is
coming along behind you who's got better
technology and better efficiencies and
so
if if the generator doesn't have an
incentive to do that why would they it
costs money to reduce costs so I I see
that as just a way to keep them in the
game if you would
okay even though I think they should be
in the market anyway
well we thank you you've given us lots
to think about
is there anybody else who would like to
Meredith Hatfield would like to address
us on a point or two
thank you chairman Vos
um just regarding the question about
could you include language to encourage
New Hampshire resources that results in
New Hampshire jobs I agree with the
prior comments about
um not wanting to run a file of the
Commerce Clause but I did just want to
point out to you that in existing law so
in RSA 362 F9 which is the existing
purchase power agreement Authority in
the RPS law there is language that
directs the puc
um
to consider actually it says doe today I
would make a plug for changing that in
this bill but I can I can do that later
but there is language requiring
consideration of Economic Development
and environmental benefits for New
Hampshire so
that is already in our law in another
section and it seems as though it has
not run afoul of the Commerce Clause so
it's an additional consideration and
actually in the in the Berlin biomass
plant
case that you know there was testimony
provided about the economic benefits and
the jobs as well as the environmental
benefits so I just wanted to call that
language to your attention because it
does seem as though it's past the
Commerce Clause challenge
thank you very much appreciate you
looking that up
okay
Mr Phelan has something to contribute
so I will pass out a piece of material
here just one moment
so I've passed out a couple of charts
here that uh may not be surprising to
some of the room but really underscore
the challenge that we see and what we're
we're looking for in a targeted solution
so first I'll point to the wholesale
prices that are linked to Natural Gas
slide because that does a good job of
illustrating a lot of points about the
New England system that we have to keep
in mind you can see extremely large
winter price spikes that are tied to the
price of natural gas
um this is the volatility that we are
aimed at combating here so while prices
may be low for most of the year and
while sometimes this these sort of
contracts these Hedges will look like a
bad deal we are looking at those big
Sprite big spikes and really considering
how those affect New Hampshire rate
payers you can also turn to the other
side where you can see the annual value
of the wholesale energy markets and
you'll notice if you flip back and forth
between the two that the higher cost
years are linked to those higher priced
Winters
so winter is driving a lot of the costs
that New Hampshire rate payers see and
winter is where some of these was where
the reliability Solutions should be
focused
I did want to say a brief word on the
circulated amended version of the bill
in particular to its references to
in-state electricity Supply the
department is very opposed to including
those within the bill itself I
understand the
the drive behind it but uh
the development of so if looking at uh
legislative findings Roman 3 the
development of reliable sources of
low-cost
electricity Supply as I would prefer is
critical to stabilizing and reducing the
cost of electricity in New Hampshire
there is not particularly a distinction
between energy Supply in New Hampshire
and energy Supply within New England
so the the wholesale prices are
relatively the same across the region
and there is not really a difference
between the reliability benefits of an
in-state and out-of-state resource I
believe there's also a reference to
in-state
um
in another in under uh Romans 3 uh
d
where it says supports the
diversification of New Hampshire's
in-state electric energy sources I I
don't believe that is uh the objective
of this bill and and I don't believe
that that should be included in a final
version thank you
okay thank you is there anyone else who
would like to make a contribution to our
discussion here this morning
seeing none what we're going to do next
is representative McGee has prepared an
amendment
2023-1464 H we're going to go through
this amendment and consider the changes
that it makes to the bill
and then we're going to decide whether
there are any further changes that need
to be made
or whether this is an amendment that
should
go forward
so Mr Phelan has pointed out that on
page one line 9 the word in state should
probably be stricken
and then on page three line 13
the phrase in state should also be
stricken I think that's
probably a good idea I know
representative McGee youth who wanted to
make sure that this bill benefited New
Hampshire ratepayers we all want that
but this does raise some
Commerce Clause issues so I think it's
reasonable to strike that language yeah
I think also where it's listed on page
three supports the diversification of
New Hampshire's electric energy sources
is fine you know I I'm not trying to put
a straight jacket on anyone I was trying
to sort of further clarify what our
objectives were and I I thought that's
what I had heard originally is that
that's where it would be focused but I
don't have any objection to those
changes okay now could you walk us
through the other changes that this
amendment
provides yeah I didn't expect that they
wouldn't be bolded
so hmm
it's going to be interesting okay so if
we start on page one in section two the
cost of electricity in New England is
driven by a number of factors including
the retirement of Base load generation
resources dependence on natural gas for
regional demand and increases in the
cost of natural gas due to International
factors I thought what we had there
originally for the second clause
which was a lack of gas I thought that
was a not the more generic language of
describing what the issue is so anyway
that's the first change and then under
Roman numeral three
um that's another place where the
in-state we just discussed taking that
out
so
um
representative Thomas has a question yes
uh
I have a question on what you uh just
said there has it not been
proven that part of the cost of our
electricity is due to the lack of
capacity of our natural gas during the
winter time
so why would we want to take that out
I think our dependence on natural gas
for regional demand is probably a more
accurate description of why the cost
went up
uh we've heard over the years that that
um
particularly in the wintertime the
capacity Factor has has really resulted
in higher costs but I just didn't know
if we wanted to take that out or not
well I I guess what I would say by way
of clarification is that it was natural
gas by prices that spiked and a lack of
sufficient or adequate Supply to meet
demand
can be satisfied by a number of
different resources that's not the only
resource that could satisfy it so that's
why I thought it should be clarified
does that make sense
well replacing the word words lack of
adequate natural gas capacity in the
winter with regional dependence on
natural gas for seasonal Peak demand
to me that doesn't seem like a like a
big change I mean it's not a hill to die
on no I think that's a that's an okay
change
so then under Roman numeral four oh well
before you go on but we do have to
consider that any change that we're
going to make is a change that the
Senate would need to accept yep so we
don't
by that I mean we don't want to make
changes just for the sake of making
changes we want to make changes that we
think are critical
to the
viability of the legislation and also
make changes that we think the Senate
would be comfortable with so
I I just throw that out as we go through
the rest of these changes please
continue I appreciate that Mr chairman
that makes sense to me
um again this section is the legislative
findings and statement of purpose so
under section four again I change the
language to make it more just objective
and statement recent Market volatility
has harmed New Hampshire's residents and
businesses so I just made it a
declarative statement it's a finding
and then under five
um
to ensure that New Hampshire rate payers
can benefit from I added low cost
energy sources to address unprecedented
price volatility so I just added the
word low and to address
um
so again just making them
any comment on those changes they seem
satisfactory to me
um okay continue and then when you skip
down to
um
the purchase power agreements section
Roman numeral 1 low-cost reliable energy
requests for proposals
the sentence after letter A
I took the word issue which was after
the date and brought it to before no
later than June 30th 2025 because
just grammar
so it basically now would read
investor-owned electric distribution
utilities may elect to develop and issue
no later than June 30th 2025 a request
for proposals because the request for
proposals piece is really where the
separation should be the word issue
didn't belong on the other end of the so
that was just a grammatical thing and
then
to continue on that sentence
um for multi-year agreements for energy
in conjunction with
or independent of any attendant
environmental attributes from electric
energy sources I originally wanted to
remove that and after I had a
conversation with other folks that
understood why that language was in
there I put it back in so I don't think
that's a change either there
so then we can skip down to
number three under that section that
starts with electric distribution
utilities shell consult with the
Department of energy the language that
was added goes down to let me just see
if I can
a new language would be on page two
starting at line one right starting at
line one right
so it says
uh the department and the office of the
consumer Advocate added languages shall
engage in independent third party with
utility purchase power agreement
expertise to help
that was added there and then the last
line of that section within this period
the utilities shall solicit public
comment
and the next section four okay before
you move on with that could I just ask
the consumer Advocate if he has any
reaction to that language
okay
sorry to put you on the spot
so the language says
the department and the office of the
consumer advocate
shall engage an independent third party
with utility purchase power agreement
expertise
to help provide any such consultation
within 60 days from the date of
from the date each draft request for
proposals is provided for its review
so if your question is would we be
willing to work with the Department of
energy to do that just what is your
reaction to that change to the
legislation I I I'm I think that if that
is what is going to help that bill
become law I'm I'm all for it we'd be
delighted to work with the Department of
energy my only concern is anytime you
ask a state agency to enter into a
contractual relationship with anybody
there's every reason to think that we'll
have to go to the governor and Council
for its approval and that tends to slow
things down so that's an issue but uh I
I we we do need that kind of independent
outside help to do a great job
um
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman so
I'm unclear as to whether this language
says the department and the consumer
Advocate each do this or collectively do
this with one independent
uh third party I I was assuming that you
meant that we and the department would
work together and jointly hire a
consultant okay that that's not clear to
me
I think it could be interpreted that you
each go out and do it
indeed that would be expensive though
and probably duplicative
I think if it said the department
or the con Office of the consumer
Advocate shall engage
that would probably indicate that they
were doing it independently but when it
says and
then I would
I would guess that that would direct
them to do it together
okay thank you Mr Chris for your
reaction
and I think I already added that the
next line within this period the utility
shall solicit public comment that was
another
comment we heard here today was that
they would like there to be some ability
for stakeholders around the process to
be able to comment so that's uh that was
changed from May to Shell yes that's a
good change I think everybody's in
agreement with that and then section
um oh go ahead Mr Roberts from the
Department of energy
not Mr faila sorry
yeah I'm just going to note that when we
were talking about the
independent third party so if you're
looking at lines the paragraph beginning
or looking at lines one and on
um that requires us to engage in
independent third party and then section
four immediately after that uh requires
us again to
hire an independent third party
um so I'm just not sure
the bill needs to have both of those so
your question is is that redundant yes
all right
let's see if we can answer that question
going back to the beginning of the
paragraph
well it does appear to be redundant yeah
and the other thing that's inconsistent
is I think we had suggested that the
utilities would be doing the actual
request for proposals
right that they would they they're
they're also going to be required to
have somebody independent work with them
so maybe this language in section four
is
I think what section 4 is trying to
achieve is to say that if they exceed in
any contracts that 10 000 that they have
to go in front of the governor and
Council right for approval so
that paragraph may be trying to
accomplish something else and I just we
were repeating language that maybe
doesn't need to be there
well the original language said
the department of energy and the
consumer Office of Consumer advocate
of the the electric distribution utility
shall consult with the Department of
energy in the office of the consumer
advocate
on all issues related to such proposals
and then you added the language about
engaging an independent third party
[Music]
but it's already in paragraph four
so maybe we don't need to add that
additional language I guess is what I'm
saying
we'll leave section three as it was
originally written yeah removed okay
except for the shell okay
all right and that addresses the
question of redundancy bye removing that
language okay next what um
what what other changes in your
Amendment representative McGee
move back here
okay so we're down to
uh in section four the department of
energy shall hire an independent third
party so that shall and independent
third party were added to section four
which is
um
online I'm sorry online five say that
again where where are we we are on line
five on page two the department of
energy shall hire an independent third
party
so
shall and and independent third party
were added
I thought these were going to be bolded
so I'm sorry for the confusion that it
came in as a replace so Department of
Veterinary Gene May hire oh shall hire
okay yep
and departed third party okay that's
that seems reasonable
and then section five was added
um electric distribution utilities shall
engage and independent third party to
perform a cost benefit analysis of any
agreements received in response to the
request for proposals such analysis
shall be provided to the commission as
part of the utilities petition for
approval of any purchase power
agreements resulting from the RFP
process so that was just to make sure
that
that a professional cost benefits
analysis would be available to the puc
since they're going to have to determine
whether it's
appropriate
and that language is acceptable to
the parties
okay
next all right well we're running down
here
um
I have to locate it in the
piece we just got let's see okay
three yep on page three
thank you JD
okay so that would be letter E Line 14
on page three
would be any other factors oh I'm sorry
let's go to C first which is on page on
line 12.
um Fosters price to billion helps reduce
customer exposure to Market volatility I
inserted
customer
I thought
or maybe it was there originally so
maybe I
I did a bunch of edits and then I backed
them out so if it's already there then I
wouldn't worry about it no it's not
there it's not there okay
oh that's right I'm looking at the
amendment that's right okay so customer
exposure was what um
I added to modify that sentence and then
in D I had added in state which we
already agreed should be backed out
again
is that correct we didn't want it we're
going to check that out yes so now we're
at e
um on line 14 which is any other factors
necessary to determine whether the
agreement is just and reasonable and in
the public interest comma
such as does the contract contain colon
performance incentives for meeting cost
projections and Generator penalties for
non-performance during demand periods to
protect rate payers from demand price
spikes and promote delivery of reliable
service
and I believe we spoke earlier about
removing the word Peak so the copy that
I'm reading already has that removed
um
but the copy you have has has peak in
there that was before the testimony
saying it's probably not a good idea
all right if we remove the word Peak
then it would say non-performance during
demand periods yep
is that
yeah that's not language that I think
the POC could interpret
easily
so if we were going to eliminate the
word Peak we would probably also have to
eliminate the words during Peak demand
periods
so then it would read
meeting cost projections and Generator
penalties for non-performance to protect
repairs from demands
so we'll strike that hole
phrase
okay next and then the next section is
section four which is on line 18 and it
says upon receiving Public Utilities
Commission approval of an agreement to
purchase electric energy in conjunction
with or independent of any attendant
environmental attributes and
investor-owned electric distribution
utility shall that's the change sell
such purchased energy and any
environmental attributes when the
wholesale Market in the man in the
manner to minimize costs and maximize
benefits to rate payers and then rather
than if I changed it to when the
electric distribution utility sells into
the wholesale Market it shall and then
there there aren't any other changes
after that
okay those are good changes I think
oh
uh is that
is that still in here
any other
comments on those changes representative
Corman
there was one other change on line 27
page three
uh where it says any Electric
Cooperative the word rural had been
removed it had said any Rural Electric
cooperatives
and and I can explain that um yes please
do Mr locata explained to me that in
statute currently that is this is the
descriptor for the only Cooperative
that's operating uh at with a
certificate of deregulation on file
which is the New Hampshire Electric
Co-op it's referred to as a Rural
Electric Cooperative so that's the
language that already exists and I
wasn't aware of that so
um
if we want to leave it in for
consistency that's fine with me
so why did you delete it then I
originally had any New Hampshire
Electric Cooperative to broaden the term
from rural because I didn't know what
rural meant and then he told me what
role meant and I'm not sure why
why it isn't back in here as well why
it's eliminated completely but
um that's how it happened that's how it
came to be anybody have a concern about
whether or not the word rural is crucial
to this language
rep Mr boo
okay so we'll put the word rural back in
then
and it also needs to go back into line
33.
two places then
okay
and those are all the changes that your
suggested amendment makes correct
um line 33 right here
I think the only other outstanding issue
that we had discussed potentially
including was
um to see if there was a place where we
could discuss
the attributes the environmental
attributes or wrecks
um I don't know if we're going to be
able to Wordsmith that and we're not
going to be able to do that today
um
but before we leave today I want to
decide if we're going to try to address
that issue but we're not going to
address it today
if we decide we're going to address it
we're probably going to have to have at
least one more work session
and we're going to have to ask for some
help in coming up with language
but we'll put that up for a minute to
make sure that
there are no other suggested amendments
here that we want to consider
putting into
the what I hope will be the committee
Amendment
chairman I have a question yes Mr
someone was brought up in a testimony
was at the very end of section three
after line e there was a suggestion
about putting in something about capping
costs
I didn't know if we want to do that in
this or if that would require a rewrite
of something else
that's a good question
um
so we're talking about
a cap of over-market costs that's
correct yeah
that is probably true
um
so this would be page three
after line 17
. all right so that's a candidate for
admission
uh addition rather to this amendment
other candidates would be page three
line ten
that was in the original bill
oh yeah this is what we're do we're just
talking about performance incentives
so that would require a new line 17. so
I'll ask members of the Department of
energy who are here
if
they think that they could help us
create language about adding
a new section F here to
suggest that the commission consider
performance caps
on over Market costs for any ppas
you need to think about that yep okay
so that would have to be
an addition that we would determine
later I guess
chairman if we are listing factors
uh that they can consider and just and
reasonable we probably could add that as
the puc should consider over market caps
right
on the cost of the PPA it just it's just
a directive it's not trying to prescribe
it I'm not sure we would be qualified to
prescribe it but
well your language says does the
contract contain colon performance
incentives for meeting cost projections
and Generator penalties for
non-performance
to protect great fairs from
demand prospects spikes
after non-performance you could insert
consideration for over-market caps
on ppas and then it would be to protect
rate payers right so you could insert it
as another
item for consideration there I think or
consideration
yeah of
over Market
energy cost
caps
over market energy
or consideration of over-market energy
cost caps okay to protect rate payers
from demand price spikes and promote
delivery reliable service
so it's just I'm not sure that
over market caps would protect rate
payers from demand price spikes
but and promote the delivery of reliable
service but
low cost
well you could just say to protect rate
payers and promote delivery of reliable
Services if you don't think it modifies
what's before it you know I mean
so those of you who have had experience
with the Public Utilities Commission in
the past
would that language be uh
illustrative for the commission or would
it be
confusing to the commission
neither
of the latter it would be confusing
come on up to the mic Tom thanks
concerned about words like over Market
because this is a competitive bid
process that goes to the puc and we I
truly anticipate that we'll be looking
at markets forecast prices all the
aspects that go into this and
in truth we don't know what's going to
be over Market or not over Market it's
meant to have
over the term of the contract net
benefits to customers
and that'll be fully explored by us by
the OCA by Third Parties by the puc
before the puc in adjudicative
proceeding so I'm not sure what language
like that actually does
just
well I think the the question arose
because recently we've all had some
direct experience with the Burgess
biopower PPA and we know it has
a cap in it for over-market energy costs
and so I think the question here is
would something similar to that be
useful for these ppas maybe it wouldn't
but that's that's the question I think
we're wrestling with right at the moment
um
and then there's always the question of
even if you thought it did
what what level was that what numbers
put in there and are you going to chill
a response of potential uh bidders on
the RFP with that
I mean we can give it some more
consideration uh
backup Doe
and and we will
but those are my initial thoughts on it
and we sort of and we sort of know
in hindsight even with 100 million cap
that's been problematic from all kinds
of different angles
obviously yes
Mr locata did you have a comment about
that question
um I guess I just throw out their
even the current additional language
such as does the contract contain and
then throwing this additional cap
language in there
you know would be worthy of perhaps more
consideration and I I understand
the intent
and I don't think we have a problem with
the intent but you know
should the utility when we're issuing an
RFP if this language is a such as
should the utility require that the
respondents have you know the contracts
coming back have performance incentives
meeting cost projections and penalties
for non-con performance there are
traditionally penalties for
non-performance in these contracts it's
just the
the ambiguity of the language
it might be difficult
um and I guess I'd you know if we're
expanding to include
price caps
Does it include price Caps or is it an
example of something that could be
considered you know there's just sort of
regulatory ambiguity that's sort of
building into this section so I I think
we would just want to be I think the
committee would want to be
cautious
um
good point
okay we'll
we'll take
that possible change
we will study that possible change
further before we consider adding it
and so I think that brings us to the
point at which we need to discover to
discuss rather what our next steps are
going to be
so
at this point in time we have the option
to try to come up with a recommendation
that we can
take to the full committee or I think a
section a second option here would be to
have another one of these work sessions
to hammer out final issues final
language
consider a couple of other possible
changes here the one that
relates to Rex and the ones that that
relates to potential
over-market energy
cost caps
now we could defer
another meeting and just say no we'll
we'll deal with deal with those other
two issues at some other time
and then just try to come up with a
single Amendment and a recommendation
for the committee or we can
have that second meeting
what's what's the sense of the committee
about whether you'd like to have a
second meeting or not
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman uh I think we've
done a lot of work on this and I think
these two issues are you know worthy of
of improving this bill so that we have a
a really solid bill that we can put
forward in the Senate we'll just say
that's great and everything will go
along smoothly so I I think let's let's
take take on these other two remaining
issues and improve the bill so that
would necess necessitate another meeting
another meeting okay
other opinions
I agree with representative Bernardi
okay
how do you guys feel I agree as well I
agree all right so we will schedule
another subcommittee meeting then for
next Monday at 10 a May 1st at 10 A.M
No 9 A.M
no sense starting late
9 A.M so bring your uh in and in the
meantime we'll work with the Department
of energy and others who are interested
uh to help us maybe craft some language
to incorporate these two ideas into the
bill
and um
and then we'll go from there
so Mr below you have a final closing
comment here
if I may I just wanted to throw out a
suggestion for you and all the other
stakeholders in the room to consider
um now rather than wait a week
um so on the renewable energy credit
issue
um where on the looking at the amendment
at line 20 where it says shall sell such
purchased energy and environmental
attributes into the wholesale Market
um I'm sorry page three
this is at line 20 where it changes from
May to Shell
um
[Music]
the utility shell sell such purchased
energy and environmental attributes into
the wholesale Market it could say there
instead say say shall sell purchased
energy and capacity into the wholesale
Market
um and then uh have a new Roman five
renumber the existing Roman five to six
and it could just read pretty simply
to the extent any proposed uh purchase
power agreement includes environmental
attributes such such as Rex
the puc or the commission shall approve
how such environmental attributes are
used or disposed of in a manner expected
to minimize costs and maximize benefits
to ratepayers
so it would just leave
the RFP open as to how that's resolved
and it you know so the the utility could
propose how we propose to deal with it
if it has the attributes and the
commission would approve it based on if
it's an approach expected to minimize
costs and maximize benefits so it leaves
all the details for future determination
okay could you read that language again
and read it slowly okay to the extent
any proposed
um
say it was going to go well it would go
after Roman 4 on page three it would be
Roman 5 and Roman existing Roman five
would become Romans 6.
so be just a new little uh section after
a Roman 4 on page three
do they extend to the extent any
proposed I'm just trying to follow the
language it says an agreement to
purchase electric energy uh but any
proposed
I guess those are the words being used
agreement to purchase electric energy
includes environmental attributes
and and you could have a little you
could say such as renewable energy
credits or not you could just say
includes environmental attributes the
Public Utilities Commission
shell
approve
how such environmental attributes are
used or disposed of
in a manner expected to minimize cost
and maximize benefits to rate payers
okay that's too fast could you send us
that text in email I will do that
and I have one other suggestion for your
consideration
um under Roman 2 that starts at the
bottom of page two there's an A and A B
and and I would ask your consideration
of
um
a different B and remember B to C and
this is just one even shorter sentence
so this would be near the top of Page
Three where it's directing the
commission uh to you know uh consider in
an adjudicated proceeding
um whether to approve uh these contracts
and the the additional sub paragraph
would be
intervening parties that Supply Power
to retail customers
in New Hampshire
shall be afforded an opportunity
to independently evaluate
the RFP responses and proposed PPA or in
the proposed purchase power agreement
priority permit public comment
um
on page two
lines
three and four
within this period the utility shall
solicit public comment that that's
public comment on the RFP that this is
regarding
[Music]
um
the once the RFP has gone forward a
proposed agreement is put forward to the
commission for review and approval
and at line 36 at the bottom of page 2
it says after notice and hearing which
presumably means an adjudicated
proceeding in which parties could
intervene because they have an interest
in it
um
that those parties be afforded an
opportunity to evaluate
the proposed art agreement which sort of
means that they have an opportunity to
access the the data that's used in such
an analysis so that you kind of have
another set of ideas I eyes I mean on
the proposal from from parties who
actually have a stake because they're
power suppliers in New Hampshire
we're going to need email with that okay
language and please use the amendment
yes 14.
64 H as the basis and specify exactly
what page and line that the okay new
text would would apply to I appreciate
it okay thank you to recognize that we
did made make some changes to that
already yeah yes well there'll be
another amendment
as long as they start from the same
starting place no I I think we could we
could make these changes to this
amendment yes add them to this amendment
yeah which would obviously require a new
it's going to require a new Amendment
anyway because we've already made
changes but
we could incorporate those changes
is there any reaction
from anyone
with regard to the changes Mr Blue just
suggested
Mr Phelan
just just that that sounds like a
massive confidentiality issue and would
essentially be opening one company's
books up to a competitor in in a very
large way as I understand the proposal
that has been made
okay that's a potential issue
um
we'll have to think about that consider
it
any other reaction
any reaction to the suggestion that we
add
a new section five on page three that
talks about
environmental attributes and approving
those Mr locata
gotcha
so like all of you sort of reacting as
I'm hearing it
um it seemed
uh it seemed a reasonable approach I
think there I did hear a reference to
capacity that is not included in the
procurement that we would would not want
its energy and potentially environmental
attributes but I think the approach
um that Mr Bulow is is lying out
you know
basically
pushing it off to the commission to kind
of sort it out among the parties is not
not a bad one on the environmental
attributes
thank you
okay so if you could give us that
language Mr below
maybe without
um
reference to capacity
okay
sure
all right so is there anything else
anybody would like to say anybody
assembled here or any members of the
committee subcommittee Mr representative
partial
thank you uh I'm just uh curious as well
they're not the working group
would like to I think I think it
particularly right stop by the way is
there any appetite for addressing
transmission costs
personally I say no but I'm open to
other reactions from subcommittee
members
I know there's other legislation
floating around that addresses
transmission
costs and and uh
transmission credits Etc so I I think we
should I think
the changes we're proposing to make this
bill are pretty significant
um
the governor the department of energy I
don't know how they're going to the
Senate I don't know how they're going to
react to these these changes so uh I I'd
say at this point let's not plan to make
any more changes other than possibly the
two that Mr below suggested
because I think it's going to be a
pretty
significant lift for some people when
they see the changes we're proposing to
make
okay anything else
so let's plan to reassemble here on
Monday May 1st at 9 00 a.m to hammer it
hammer out the final language for a an
amendment that we will propose to the
full committee
now
we could call in the full committee that
day to have an exact session
what what does the committee think about
that
great idea
okay so I will also schedule an
executive session for that day
pardon
we're not going to need to vote how
about
what keeps it even
what time is your uh
all morning
could you get here by two o'clock
we could do the exact session at two
o'clock
because that way we could we could have
all morning to hammer out the details of
this language get it over to OLS so that
they can hammer out the new Amendment we
can all go have a leisurely lunch and
then come back here at two o'clock for
exec session
that sound reasonable
done deal
okay that's the plan then
so I'll get that in the works with um
Christy and and the other
folks on the house Community Committee
services staff and we'll get that the
calendar for next week
and I think with that we can officially
draw this meeting to a close and I want
to thank everybody for your
participation really appreciated your
information your input and your account
wise counsel and uh
we'll just go forward from here and see
what happens so thanks
foreign